[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
où
à dix mois de ses juges et experts il
veut faire une soirée d'affilée sur
paris première non
sur les spéciales sur moi quel jour vite
avril c'est sûr c'est pas le premier
round non le 8 avril il y aura quoi de
la caisse qui m'a dit qu'est ce qui est
à ryadh vont mettre ta pièce sexe
magouille jamais été meilleure caméra
cachée aux doctes on court métrage et
des buildings en effet pour la sortie du
tree de bagnols ici avec bigard
sellem
final c'est bien qu'il ait dit de
m'asseoir et si jacques expert nous
venons d'où le nom
mais tu l'as tu l'a capté tapiès ouais
ouais ouais et alors bah ça fait bizarre
démoraliser le bébé quoique évolutive
qui a bougé l'impro tous les soirs
comment tu peux comment tu peux le cinq
heures de bonus cinquième jour de bonus
on a filmé pendant quatre ans on a fait
les cons tous les théâtres on a foutu le
bordel partout a tout filmé tout filmé
on est en belgique
et on nous fait on nous demande de faire
le journal télévisé à 13h01 en tournée
moi je suis crevé on se couche tard ses
parents lève tôt jeudi c'est hors de
question il nous dit c'est pas possible
si le journal c'est le pernaut le calvez
venir vite d'accord m condition n'a pas
le temps de s'habiller on y va tous en
peignoir ils ont fait à aa j'étais
arrivé à l'intérieur j'en étais l'elysée
la nouvelle télé fisc belge est réelle
la legendary ouais je lai on a fait
france 2 en string en a fait
jill oui au secours on parle de cette
pièce
qui a passionné pour le sandre non mais
des fois tu entends bouger les timides
il peut rester bien en place ont sonné à
sa rencontre soit pour le savoir non
mais surveille le ce passionné jeter un
oeil dans le judas après ce que
peut-être il est derrière à se ronger
les ongles non c'est un vide il a l'air
comme ça un peu mais l'ensemble de leurs
d'habitude c'est qu'à nous même tout
seul au resto et qu' il est temps de
manger puis voir on passe alors qu'il
doit te tuer je vais me vois ça lui
coûte la petite deux fois par former
trois fois de la version wii mais
j'avais des hémorroïdes je ne sais pas
je vous demander aux jeunes
ça c'est de la vanne de fédérateur post
22 cuisine j'adore j'étais avec mon
ordinateur du wild todd c'est à mon avis
c'est un électricien après son rédacteur
donne même le patron de la télé il se
borne à qui ça m'étonnait avait pas
qu'il ya des foyers l'amateurisme ou
jeudi dans tout le combat et c'est lui
je pas prête
je fais plaisir de revoir ouais ah oui
il était super sympa avec moi l'autre
jour
président thierry j'allais bien je veux
pas de ça tout les autres vous la
raconter
surtout
si on m'avait dit président quand vous
êtes venu en parle on m'avait dit c'est
dommage content d'être là thierry may a
pas bac c'est vrai ce soir d'ailleurs
j'ai dit que je et je regardais plus
appréciés du tibre l espagne la revoilà
oh non merci il faut un peu les poches
pardon c'est
un peu les policiers
fouillent page et vous mettrais bien là
tout va bien
bravo j'ai de la porcelaine
très estimable que je voulais offrir un
précédent bravo là une belle cuisine la
cuisine est cédée casino fait plaisir
dans le rang là oui je suis très content
c'est vrai c'est sincère en train de le
voir j'apprécie ça la vigueur et la
rapidité de ses réparties
et s'est jamais à côté de la plaque je
sais ça voilà c'est pour le président de
csc la constatation ils ont laissé sa
tête et parfois non
moins mais je trouve que c'est mieux à
vous trouvez qu'il a été moins souvent
qu'avant en bas un certain moment il
était tombé un petit peu dans la
vulgarité il ya très longtemps et puis
moi je trouve que maintenant il et j'ai
maintenant des failles fait rire
intelligemment
des choses une chose assez rare
aujourd'hui il ya un esprit de répartie
j'ai constaté qui fait rire les autres
aussi y compris les plus sérieux wim
après un truc que l'asim a semé près
avec une jeune fille en fait dans la vie
oui c'est qu'en fait n'importe quel
personnage même le plus haut placé oui a
été un enfant oui donc si vous arrivez
et suzette déférents le type va vous
regarder de haut il va vous faire payer
votre infériorité mais si vous jouez
avec lui si vous commencez à lui a dis
donc toi là tu as vu ce que tu as là et
où si vous jouez com avec un gosse le
mec va craquer surtout que c'est pas
négative ce que je dis là au contraire
bafia une âme d'enfant voilà c'est vrai
à la vôtre président on va écouter
thierry à vous à la vôtre 1 santé
bonheur et joie dans ta soeur voilà et
et votre book hasard écoutez il vient
d'être mis en vente
alors j'en sais rien moi d'un essai
aucune liste dans les parts de nous oui
mais pas seulement j'ai joué je crois
dire des choses un petit peu à
contre-courant la grossièreté se trouve
ailleurs elle se trouve dans la dans la
télé réalité27 nombre d'émissions qui
moi me est d'accord car elles paraissent
beaucoup plus grossières et que les
grossièretés je viens tous les jours les
gens savent pas l'autre jour on avait la
princesse de kent oui la princesse de
cannes vient pour son bouquin sur diane
de poitiers et catherine de médicis et
puis après l'interview je lui dis quand
même votre père était nazi
vous même vous avez défendu le celui là
le pari celui camille la croix gamée et
celtique
oui oui mais à l'époque c'est tout le
monde était nazi du nom de bord tout le
monde était pas nazi à l'époque et le
lendemain elle m'appelle mais dit il
faudrait le coupé j pourquoi elle m'a
dit parce que c'est de mauvais goût
sinon ce qui est de mauvais goût c'est
l'asie bah oui mais voilà
[Musique]
personne
et la santé vous marchez est venu à pied
je suis anti jeu artix gras attendent
simplement
soit pour fort bonsoir oui au quatrième
étage
[Musique]
gore j'ai une énorme râteau
mais vous savez hervé va de 6 800 mètres
c'est lui à son bureau c'est en trois
quarts d'heure
de rage ou quand les gens dans la rue
toujours et j'ose imaginer plus grands
après j'aime pas bonnes gueules cassées
vous vouliez vous avez retrouvé les
joies fassent du sport deux fois par ses
montants 6 et des rencontres tant que je
peux tu nous fais par exemple un des
rencontres extraordinaires
dans gmail est là pour l attaque
mais surtout messieurs bonsoir
bonsoir bonsoir
des personnes ont fui moi vos manteaux
numéro deux veste homme et vous y est
attendu à la cuisine à ses parents
[Musique]
et les cuisiner
la voix
ah oui au fait
bonjour jo ça va je me lève plus parce
que j'ai le dos cassé ses parents qui se
tapaient je sais pas justement j'ai le
dos cassé pour choisir la natation temps
qu'il les verrait natation avec le
président bush a demandé à hervé si son
livre marché utilisé que il savait pas
encore non c'est trop tôt c'est moche et
qui sont repartis un retirage je suis là
c'est ma deuxième au général en général
quand on dit c'est trop tôt c'est que ça
se vend pas
ça se lit comme un roman il faut être
sûr ces chiffres vous avez sans aucun
président wim jeux sociaux les jeux
roubaix je sais pas besoin de le lire
j'ai vu le parisien ce matin et j'ai vu
que vous veniez beaucoup mon cher petit
rien alors m'a beaucoup moins c'est très
très bien peinard je suis dernier
salaire moi je suis 21e moi ça dépend ce
qu'on appelle mon gérant latine tout est
relatif donc je verrais que la quiche
chez ces gens là je plaisante la menara
vous avez moi je suis 21e moi je suis
derrière tout le monde ces quartiers on
a fait ce matin ouais pour venir le
chiffre est un bon gars aiment beaucoup
moins vous devez pas être content j'ai
eu les premiers coups reçus
elle a donc imaginé le premier le
premier c'est le lait ouais le deuxième
c'est de la rue
wayne * il ya de la rue c'est ça avec
mes sept jeux ces salaires ça oui c'est
ça la petite la série que c'est ça on
voir à la boîte de prod c'est ce que
j'explique à dos et moi c'est pas les
vrais salaires ça parce que ça y est il
est vrai se paye ce qu'ils veulent ils
ont intérêt à pas beaucoup se payer un
bon voire gagner plus d'argent
pour voir gagner plus d'argent
mais quel délice mais je vais le faire
quelqu'un sait pas ce que vont penser
les semis capuchon déjà mécontent de
voir certains est au coeur de la
politique utilise à côté de ça bon il ya
une temps etc bon ben ça c'est la vraie
question aujourd'hui comment agissez
gens même rapport à cette question je
sais pas j'en sais rien la différence
d'un autre métier j'en connais où ils
sont bien payés ils continuent à
regarder la télé alors qu'ils vont plus
voir le psg oui c'est vrai oui mais du
matin avait été placée pour savoir c'est
un boulot instable un oui ben oui vous
regardez moi j'ai quand même passé
quatre ans au bord de la route pas à
cause de moi c'est comme un footballeur
tient du rayon masquer un footballeur
non un animateur regarder drucker il n'a
pas 30 ans maintenant 60 langues mais si
ça avait qu'à voir les drucker au regard
de chat yanni 120000 euros par mois
gagnons rien cette année
quand vous regardez les salaires des
responsables des chaînes de télévision
publiques et que vous comparer aux
autres
moi j'étais président tf1 mais c'est
gagner rien successeur a gagné 3,4 fois
plus vous le savez oui mais moi à
l'époque je gagnais à l'époque un rayon
tv dans les années 80 3,85 c'était de
l'ordre en francs à l'époque de 50000
par mois à l'époque sa deuxième
quinzaine de séries ne l'est pas quand
même aujourd'hui je ne sais pas je n'ai
pas regardé le salaire de tessier tout
le monde dans ce sens entre quinze et
vingt mille euros elisabeth
main comme il gagne 100 milles ouais en
france ça fait sens et vous 50 ans
lillers et le président de l'oedt et
fins et ses 220 mille euros c'est 700
milles ou un milieu où ça fait sept fois
arthur a appelé pour dire quoi pour dire
que c'est des passes à son salaire et
qu'ils gagnaient 25000 euros non
mais alors qu'est-ce qui réponde quand
on lui dit oui m'enfin arthur d'accord
on parle du salaire mais les à-côtés
artistique aux critiques ont des
salaires telefonica qui a racheté
endemol me doit une fortune non mais lui
dit oui effectivement j'ai gagné
beaucoup d'argent en vendant ma société
s'adresse pas de souci mais voilà mon
salaire c'est ça et il m'a dit je peux
même temps envoyé ma fiche de paye si je
veux oui et pour quel produit à
l'antenne pour tout ce qui fait à
l'antenne auditive puisqu'il mais oui
mais bon au niveau qualité pourra tout
de même ça c'est un autre débat
doublé vabre et génère bien public ouais
moi ya beaucoup d'émissions qui me
plaisent pas il yad'autres kim
l'émission la plus vulgaire pour vous
c'est la gale a beaucoup cherché rien
dans les chiffres et les lettres une
fois ils vont me reculer comme moi j'ai
trouvé ça très vulgaire et c'est
pourtant des émissions respectable à la
basse et du bac fille de l'excellent
golf mais c'est vrai que ça aurait pu
être coupée
dis moi tu as reçu hervé bourges dans
ton émission bon sens lire il ya des
gens qui ont téléphoné oui bien sûr
qu'est ce qu'ils ont dit des choses
plutôt sympa c'était plutôt sympathique
martel gentilhomme ces personnels ces
syndicats furieux le gentilhomme de
télévision j'ai peut-être la première
fois qu'on me dit ça mais ça me fait
plaisir il a eu il est la seule attaque
qui a eu c'était sur les minorités
visibles à la télévision où on lui
disait mais aujourd'hui vous battez pour
qui de plus en plus de minorités
visibles et pourquoi vous n'avez pas
fait quand vous y étiez c'est un peu
facile de se battre après que j'ai
expliqué qu' à l'époque comment s'était
fait rappeler quand même j'étais le
premier à introduire quelqu'un était
foutu à la porte après par tf1 c'est
nadia samir oui oui c'est vrai oui j'ai
recruté d'asnières samy est gelée mis à
l'antenne en 81 4 e mais c était
expliqué oui oui il avait quand même le
français sait bien que rien mais c'est
une personne attendait mais j'en ai
plutôt tripler à l'époque c'était
extrêmement difficile on n'en parlait
pas tant qu'ange évoqué c'est est-ce que
vous souvenez quand j'ai été nommé
président de tf1 parce que vous souvenez
notre ami bruno masure a fait avec sa
face ici habituel ses facéties habituel
une fausse note de service signée du
nouveau pdg hervé bourges 10 ans tous
les vendredis couscous à la cantine tous
les soirs un sujet sur l'afrique tous
les week-ends un truc sur le monde arabe
parce que je venais avec cette
réputation alors et votre surnom aux
deux tiers de 2010 oui c'est ça
donc à l'époque j'aurais recruté au nom
ait dit ça y est qu'est ce que c'est que
ce type et cgg de faire très attention
même si j'essayais de c'est quand même
moi qui ai lancé les nuits du ramadan
c'est moi ça m'intéresse avoir contredit
c'était difficile a les poches de
traîner ça veut dire quoi concrètement
cet été les spectateurs écrivait les
gens écrivaient s'est passé à ces
primaires la tutelle à ces paiements
même pas non non c'était bon ben voilà
on n'imaginait pas qu'il y avait dans
notre société des gens de couleurs
historiques avoir du talent qui se
manifestait qui disait petit dizaine ont
cessé d'exister rien mais c'est c'était
comme ça c'était le non dit et ça
continue et jusqu'à il ya très peu de
temps dont sur une certaine gêne un
certain moment il était inquiet pour les
fictions il ne fallait pas de héros
récurrent noirs ou arabes oui oui
c'était parce que vous êtes a voulu dire
c'est un jeu du je ne dirai pas le nom
ce n'est peut-être pas tes fins alors
oui bonsoir bonsoir vous avais tu me
alain de greef au quatrième étage merci
beaucoup
m
dix ans commence à douter ça
ap
[Musique]
c'est monsieur bonsoir
c'est ici
aux vêtements
pas
[Musique]
c'est aussi carole vergne est ici
remplacé à la kahina d'abord merci
ouais y'a que des mecs qui sautera vieux
traquenard
salut salut
et bape il a dit tu vas voir il va y
avoir un noir est pas mal le côté grâce
à dieu grâce à dieu c'était dans la
résidence il était quand même temps que
tu ma vie parce que c'est que j'habite à
quoi la médiane et
voilà les blacks qui sont dans les beaux
quartiers maintenant
aujourd'hui à tf1 il ya un black lake et
la météo la mecque mais il fait pas de
la météo justement oiseaux sur les
connais pas il fallait se méfier des
clichés dans le black qui fait la météo
parce qu'il a le soleil dans la photo
qui qui présente une émission de sport
parce que c'est bien connu on évite que
les blancs ou à la musique facile on en
rythme dans la peau mais ce qui est
intéressant ce moment c'est qu'on sort
des clichés à une blague par exemple le
journal sur france 3 dans le droite sont
aimés cinq ou sept mois qui présentent
une émission culturelle sur donc ça va
bien il est noir
je reviens sur l'île il
serait bien non n'empêche que paulin il
fait quoi que les vidéos gags la météo
quand même si tu ne sais pas mais il est
pas vraiment de
manière t'amusant d'ailleurs voir que
c'est ce gouvernement qui a fait prendre
conscience que les minorités visibles
n'était pas oui tout à fait
le premier c'est ça ça a été moi mes
premiers politique ça a été maintenant
alors à partir de ce moment là moi quand
j'ai réunissait les présidents de
chaînes par exemple pour leur dire
attention il ya un vrai problème et il
faut que vos programmes reflète la
réalité de la france d'aujourd'hui qui
inquiète qui est une réalité métissé bon
les gens disaient bon très bien les ecos
toujours les autres bon on va faire ce
qu'on peut et puis le gouvernement s'est
saisi de cette affaire les dix il faut
que alors voilà que tout à coup
maintenant ceux qui étaient les plus
effacés dans ce domaine deviennent de
vrais militants de
voilà merci et
caetera et on voit tout à coup des gens
qui sont recrutés le vrai problème c'est
un problème de société quand est ce que
notre société prendra conscience de ça
et ça c'est pas un texte réglementaire
ou une loi qui fera évoluer
étoilé
je fais partie de la génération qui a
essuyé les plâtres dire juste d'une
battre quatre fois plus à dit être prise
de risque
justement tente oui ça jonathan longues
séquences vraiment en quoi c'est un mot
de sondage est est ce que tu as vu les
sondages à reuters que c'est un truc
technique on s'aperçoit qu'il ya un
segment la population qui aiment ça
reste que tu as vu des résultats de
sondages te concernant les jeunes ce gym
le mouvement mais je sais juste en tout
cas que moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui un
vrai décalage en tout cas dans la
représentation des minorités vivent à la
télé entre la france d'en haut et la
france d'en bas la france d'en bas moi
je vais faire le téléthon à moins que ça
a commenté des courses doigts etc pour
france 2 il est les gens ils se disent
pas un c'est la présentatrice noir de
temps déjà c'est la tentatrice voilà en
revanche soieries la france d'en haut je
mets en déplacement même festival de la
bande dessinée pour mieux et c'est la
france dans rouge en temps j'aime
beaucoup votre émission et puis vraiment
vous avez une très bonne diction avait
bien sûr moi y en a
je bois de l'eau et oui malheureusement
ces condamnés à ça pendant quelques mois
et alors mais ça va c'est fait
mais si tu veux ça a été un
bouleversement dans ma vie mais
maintenant ça fait six ans donc alors
moment j'y arrive très très bien mais
non là particulièrement en ce moment
avec les histoires de rayon en
permanence sage peu plus là ça ne
m'arrache la gueule si je bois de
l'alcool donc je touche pas mais sinon
je bien sûr des qui a dû donc voir jeu
j'en profite mais pas soit
détourné au toit avec hannah téter plus
loin je suis de suite et ont défini
depuis deux ans toutes deux ans était
sous directeur ou la non non non non non
non mettons sur lorient j'ai touché les
gens aiment tout va très bien merci aux
gens ont besoin de travailler là bas
j'ai failli autant que j'aurais souhaité
est contre allée stif irait donc je suis
battu et ça m'a usé comme aux six mois
ou un an et demi d'ailleurs plus tôt
mais ça va je vais pas me plaindre c'est
pas l'heure que si tu veux pas du tout
du tout d'un coup tu sais comment il a
une indemnité toi non sinon
excusez moi car dieu sait pas combien
tôt jusqu'à 2200 euros par émission
c'est tout deux mille euros savez
combien 12000 à dire en face 1014
largement au dessus de ça
le talent rozon c'est-à-dire qu'elle
mérite quand même
tu sais la tulette émission aussi
quartier
il est de plus en plus consensuel ouais
c'est vrai
récemment et puis s'est trouvé que ok je
n'aime pas non plus maintenant ça va ça
suffit que c'est bien
pendant la terreur de jure c'est fini
moi c'est la position que j'ai pression
elle est interne avoir été mis au jour
on a même qui au quatrième étage on
approche
droite de face
tous les billets du convoi black l'or et
de l'argent il ya du mali y a pas qu'à
dater l'épave au fond c'est pareil un
mec qui rêve de marquer des buts en
trois matches c'est un connard grosse
différence c'est que dans le fond dans
le cas du football c'est la presse qui
fait la vraie glace et la télé sont les
gens eux mêmes qu'ils le font entre eux
c'est totalement différent c'est vrai
les centres e
rien
j ou rouler
[Musique]
passé par là un petit tour en cuir
oui oui ça
ma beauté
les quotas sont respectés précédent
la mort des deux femmes le favori mais
on est loin de la parité
moi je m'en foutais
si tu veux tacitement la table oui
c'est
je
[Musique]
remarque sur les réussites de chanter
comme lui
watchmen une fois c'était pâques c'est
bon c'est la seule force des batteries
mois ratés tu l'as dit je suis désolée
qui m'a dit je suis désolée
yamina tu es là
cela
l'holographie ici quand elle ici de
grève ici elisabeth là bas
[Musique]
style de cette pièce est grand style
aussi regroupée
semble laisser les gens mais j'étais
parmi tout un peuple
là
c'est bien maintenant mais j'adore que
celui-ci répéteurs à bien
génial
regardez le protéger
c'est la première fois que je vois ça un
petit coussin pour ses fesses et son
côté recevoir
princesse orientale
nathan pierre bellemare et l'on mange
non mais attendez on ne peut parler de
venir alberman on est obligé de se taire
pour écouter les histoires
extraordinaires et et pda oui qu'est-ce
qui la ppd c'est trop facile
il a brossé genre aux gaffes
compagnie là
nous c'est terrible c'est jean la
première compagnie qui sont obligés
d'aller là pour essayer d'exister encore
ses principales lignes actions
extrêmement large
je trouve ça navrant danis
effectivement une lecture et ce n est en
tout cas mais voilà tant pis mais ce
sont des gens qui connaissent le système
d je suis pas d'accord et semer people
et tout ils savent très bien qu'ils vont
en chier il décide d'en chine pour
revenir alors je suis pas
du
brésil en plus pour revenir sur le
devant de la scène
quelle histoire derrière présent il a
envie d'exister mais ils font de la
peine parce que quand on voit le trou
que jean roucas qui fait la première
compagnie en espérant revenir en
deuxième partie de soirée sur tf1 c'est
ce qu'il dit avec une émission comique
et qu'on le voit en train de péter sûr
avant salle louis à 19 heures sur tf1 je
me dis qu'il est mort et le rapport avec
l'horaire
quand mitterrand était en grenouille ces
deux c30 les guignols
show président quand vous faites un
complément pour mettre tes pieds en fait
d'accord je suis désolé le bébête show
était quelque chose de particulier
si les premiers et pendant je suis
pendant pendant toute une transgression
c'est parce que là ils ne sont pas sous
vrai mais ça n'avait rien drôle vous
repassez les bandes maintenant on est
consterné jeu mais quand vous reprenez
le dvd des guignols ya plein de choses
sont très très drôle oui bien il fait 10
ans je suis d'accord c'était la france
de giscard points
la chance est différent c'est mitterrand
ça s'arrête avec mitterrand et des
guignols c'est chirac ça s'arrêtera avec
chirac malheureusement 2007 vie voilà
c'est clair
les guignols de
césar totale parce que c'était un cadeau
que m'a écrit alain duverne le type qui
fabrique des marionnettes à la fin de la
1ère à de la première année on a eu vers
certains moments au mois de juin et je
leur ai dit qu'on ne renouvelaient
démission ou admet et donc au mois de
juin je me suis retrouvé le jour de mon
anniversaire avec ma marionnette que
j'ai emporté chez moi ils sont venus me
l'a kidnappée et ils s'en sont servis
ils me l'ont jamais rendu demandé en
partant il ya deux ans de guerre et plus
n'ont envoyé une petite statue est très
joli mais qui n'a rien à voir avec le
mari
est le premier des guignols à utiliser
les gens de la télé c'est à dire montrer
nos jeunes les deux greffes lescure ils
ont popularisé alain et moi ils m'ont
tué
ils ont été d'une violence
c'était très très dur en plus tous les
soirs c'est tel acharnement ils ont été
violentés béninois
jean marc chamard qu'incarnait le la
l'île de tf1 c'était ça été re classe
c'était pour pour l'éviter rival il ya
une magie c'est des méchants regarder
une chose tu à l'époque que tu venais tu
venais du journalisme tu sais cette
émission sur tf1 et aujourd'hui tu es
retourné au journalisme en fait un
journaliste qui étaient des voiliers
pendant quelques années mais moi à
l'époque quand ils m'attaquent est pour
entrevue c'est pareil je j'ai été dévoyé
par rapport à ce que je sais faire rien
par rapport à ce que je fais aujourd'hui
c'était très mauvais de faire mes
preuves donc quelque part ils nous ont
aidés quand même à l'embryon fait du mal
du mal en profondeur et mais il tombait
des étangs aider à comprendre que
c'était possible c'était de la merde
d'accord ils ont aidé à le comprendre
mais humainement quand cette cantate
détruit événement au camp quand tu te
demandes si tu dois continuer ce métier
quand tu te demandes où aller quand tu
te demandes si tu vois fin quand tu as
des idées très noir à cause de ça parce
que tu te sens harceler et à des preuves
en des idées noires dans ta vie voilà à
ce moment là tu dis qu'ils vont trop
loin et c'était 30 et tous les soirs
quand et tous les soirs à l'antenne et
quand tous les soirs systématiquement ce
flip ta gueule et que les gens dans la
rue après ont cette image mais tu
souffres en tant que personne problème
c'est qu'il a des facilités et ça chante
sur des ficelles alors que moi quand
l'époque où je parlais encore gassion
est gelée avant qu'il ne fasse en
marionnettes je dis mais pourquoi vous
faites pas le pen fait un potentiel
énorme il m'a dit non mais ça on sait
pas le traité donc sous prétexte que le
mec ne s'est pas le traité par mois de
conviction de talent je sais pas à quoi
donc ils baissent les bras et va
s'acharner sur un mur un coup ou s'il
survit ras jédir gros à jouer je
dirais je dis que le mec qui sait pas
traiter
le pen mais qui prennent pas le boulot
pour lequel le pen mais sa part toujours
d'un truc vrai quand même laurent salomé
- franchement j'étais contre bits et de
l'utiliser si on devait mettre le pen et
se marrer avec le pen s'il ya quelque
chose qui me choquait moi je suis
franchement je demandé
d'accord sortait sur ben laden parce que
j'avais dire ben laden portait leur
meilleur personnage est un personnage à
fait la même proxy
même dangerosité c'est à dire c'est
beaucoup plus vicieux parce que ben
laden quand on le transforme en épicier
tu sais ça c'est tu sais quand notre
grand truc c'est décoloniser les
imaginaires on est dans quelque chose
moi en tout cas moi je les ressentis
comme ça plus le côté débonnaire alors
que c'est catastrophique quoi ben laden
on l'assimilé
6000 épicière
c'est comme si grave comme c'est grave
ta gueule kaunas où schéma qui voit les
d'un seul coup on imagine tu
ramènes à quelque chose qui est ici qui
est de l'ordre de l'invisible d'ascq où
tu rend visible ce que le le père
maghrébins qui n'a jamais été justement
visible la télévision on le ramène avec
la la tronche de ben laden quoi enfin
moi je les ai vécus comme ça c'est pas
vécu du tout comme un comme un truc mon
dénonce ben laden s'est passé regrette
encore plus pervers sur l'espèce de
kaunas je pense vraiment pour les
connaître que c'est absolument pas des
types misogyne ex trouve ça horrible ils
le font dire ils lui font dire le east
peace de kaunas et dans le public les
rires parts c'est ça moi c'est ce qui
m'a fait le plus peur c'est à dire
partez donc c'est devenu le gimmick
c'est là où ces étrangers
moi j'ai vu je t'ai vu tu te fais remet
petit à petit
problème à l'époque et je trouvais ça
déplacé que d'en parler et je suis pas
un type qui parle de sa vie privée mais
tu vois j'étais jeune est père de mon
père donc j'étais pas du tout dans ce
type là j'étais dans dans la dépression
et je voyais les gens en enfoncé à terre
je voyais ces ces connards qui qui qui
font feu de tout bois et qui font des
procès d'intention donc jamais démonter
la mécanique je voyais comment ils
précédaient je voyais cet acharnement et
j'avais simplement d'autres problèmes à
régler j'en avais j'étais petit j'étais
pas là quoi j'étais un slogan espoir
mais c'est vrai qu'à l'époque moi je
savais pas gildas qui mettait la main
sur la cuisse pour pas qu'ils
interviennent c'est tout c'est comment
assumer son sniper parce qu'en face le
problème c'est ça c'est quand tu prends
le rende ma fille qu'il met pas la main
sur la cuisse pour qu'ils parlent pas
dit quand justement au contraire qu'elle
lâche sont assez stricts moi je voudrais
vous raconter une anecdote qui vient de
m'arriver aux césar donc j'ai remis un
petit isabella présidente et cetera
machin tout ça je me prends la tête je
me dis à un moment donné j'associe c'est
à la discrimination etc
tout se passe bien
j'arrive je te jure 14 secondes isabelle
va rentrer en scène je suis hamels
adjani est justement la présente
je me dis je maîtrise le truc tout va
bien et je te jure il y à une chaise au
milieu entre le sas entre la scène et
derrière je me prends la chaise je me
fais le gadin de ma vie je suis en sang
et je rentre dans ma tête moi je suis en
kit et je sais même pas ce que c'est pas
du tout aperçu que tu t'es ça c'est pas
vu mais isabelle adjani en revanche dans
les deux cas n'y arrivait pas mais toi
mais elle était absolument bien mais
elle avait vraiment envie de passer fait
20 ans qu'elle refuse des césar mais là
elle avait envie de faire passer un
message de tolérance et en même temps
sans choquer le cinéma enfin c'est quand
tu essayes de faire
vraiment mais son message principal elle
n'était pas là juste pour venir
celle de médiatisation on la voit
partout en faisait jamais avant elle
fait des interviews des photos partout
la une de tous les magazines alors en
matériels de magasinage
la question par rapport aux césar je te
réponds sur les césar non mais je te dis
avec ses pierres mon avis c'est par
hasard quoi je pense que c'est dans un
jeu de stratégie de promo non mais ce
que veut dire j'en sais ce que veut dire
jean marc en fait
elle fait moins de films en ce moment où
quand elle fait des films ils ont moins
de succès on voit bien présent mais
c'est un peu pathétique quoi c'est le
cha cha cha cha voilà exister match
érige la provo malgré tout sans faire de
film ça reste quand même une sacrée
c'est
bien sûr une des rares
chez moi je suis qu'elle se gâcher quand
elle fait la une des magazines en
parlant de ses histoires d'amour moi je
suis désolé ça me choque c'est pas il
avait déjà dit que j'aime qui est une
star pendant des années ça a été une
star mystérieuse elle était géniale pour
toi parce que mettez mystérieuse et
pendant des années la huant nuit ouais
pourquoi tout à coup sachant la triche
sur ces histoires d'amour en plus bas
rhinois signé m'a étonné c'est la
glorification du cocufiage mais oui on
s'en fout moi je m'en tape why not non
pas white est sûr mais j'ai trop de
respect pour elle moi j'ai trop de
respect pour elle parce que c'est
inquiète c'est tim ash ouais mais en
même temps s'ils tapent situe un mec tu
plantes comme ça tu as envie de le dire
surnom étudie une fois tu fais pas 10
ans est revenu sauf que c'est un génie
dont on fait 10 c'est une grande dame
quand une grande âme tu effaces 10
interview sur le fait qu'ils allaient
plus éric son maquis calais caucus je
suis déjà là c'est tellement pas ça que
moi je connais mais ce qui la fait
tourner tourner
j'en sais rien mais elle pose donc comme
elle tourne pas elle a quand même envie
faire là mais tout le monde la connaît
leur vie de faire la une des magazines
mais si l envie et comme elle tourne pas
belle parle de jean michel jarre parce
que voilà elle peut pas parler de son
film et c'est vrai qu'on a ri non mais
attends excuse moi à yamina c'est la
vérité
thierry dit thierry dis moi j'ai morflé
parce que je faisais entrevue en
interview junte qui me correspond pas
alors qu'on sait créative et c est elle
morte parce que c'est une immense
comédienne une immense star une beauté
incroyable elle raconte que jean michel
jarre l'a pas envoyé de sms c'est
lamentable c'est pour ça qu'elle elle
mange c'est donc parce que ce qu'elle
montre d'elle n'est que le côté noir de
la chose le côté négatif le côté
pathétique pour moi je sais pas ce que
vous en pensez
j'ai fait sa connaissance
excuse moi et à bourges qui le paraître
est
un moment c'est un petit gardien
tu mets ton voile moi c'est bien ben ali
vas-y mohamed à toi
c'est vrai qu'à canal tu as donné
beaucoup de liberté aux gens et tout le
monde tu en sais gré évidemment tu sais
très bien mais moi j'ai peur quand même
si tu veux sur france 2 que le jour où
ce soit privatisée on n'est plus la même
liberté mais c'est une sangsue créateurs
d'aujourd'hui parce que sa folle
ambiance à la fois la recherche des
audiences avant il va falloir trancher
là dedans pour parfaire les deux quoi
vous payer vos temps pourquoi veux tu
qu'on soit obligé de trancher entre
l'audience mais parce qu'on dit pour
faire du service public il faut faire la
qualité en même temps regarder
l'audience le lendemain donc c'est pas
possible de faire les deux en même temps
que parce qu'on ne peut pas concilier
les deux mais bourges si demain france 2
et plus
précisément et privatisé quand tu es
d'accord mais la nuit blanche une
émission sur l'art contemporain sur
france culture passera
la peau les manches fatto
je pourrais pas d'origine la nuit
blanche
moi on me l'a même si tu veux c'est que
il ya un président de france télévisions
qui a souhaité effectivement défaire
france 2 l'équivalent de tf1 qui est à
souhaiter ce
n'est pas du tout contradictoire mais
mais qui a tenté quelque chose qui
effectivement a foutu un petit peu les
jetons à tf1 et on lui a dit dehors tu
penses quelques abacha a été viré parce
qu'il a essayé de rivaliser avec tf1 oui
voilà c'est parce que il s'en est donné
les moyens ya jean il avait une bonne
partie des animateurs d'essayer d'aller
plus loin et je crois que c'est comme ça
qu'on construit aussi une concurrence à
tf1 bon bah ça anglais interdiction ont
donc on met un frein là-haut genre il
faut pas aller là mais en même temps il
faut quand même gagné 50% de sa vie ou
presque avec la publicité et je skie
déconne l'habilité fondamentalement pas
bien d'autant plus que par ailleurs les
politiques démagogiquement n'augmente al
n'augmente pas la redevance en fonction
des moyens nécessaires aux services
publics et un sous-financement endémique
alors moi je crois je prêche pas pour la
privatisation suivra lagardère je m'en
fous j'ai dit simplement voilà moi j'ai
trouvé une idée comme ça il semble
résoudre ce problème là qui permettrait
aux services publics d'être complètement
dégagée de publicité maintenant s'il ya
d'autres idées tant mieux autant le 30
mai pour y en a pas eu d'accord et en
plus je comprends pas pourquoi on
continue à créer des chaînes publiques
pourquoi est-ce qu'on va créer france 4
la caisse que vous avez quelques
services publics ces normes ont arrêté à
vous montrer les chaînes de service
public mais pourquoi le rôle de l'état
c'est pas de créer des chefs de service
ni pourquoi arrêter pas là pour ça
pourquoi moi si tu veux je vais te dire
au début des années 80 j'étais assez
libérale parce que tout était étatiques
en france il n'est pas de radio privée
pas de télé privée pas de compagnie
aérienne privée tout était étatique donc
c'est vrai que j'étais assez partisan du
libéralisme etc et puis j'ai vu ce que
c'était j'ai vu que finalement
les compagnies privés d'avion les lignes
intérieures c'était pire que l inter si
c'était possible c'était encore pire et
puis j'ai vu que tf1 le mieux disant
culturel
mais la télé devenait moins bien la
télévision un rôle social
la télévision n'est pas là que pour
enrichir les actionnaires la télévision
un rôle social sentant les jambes sans
parler d'école sans parler des corps
temps sans parler d'école du peuple
parce que longtemps on a cru et michel
polac en a été longtemps on a cru que tu
es les gens pouvaient être l'école du
peuple je pense pas que l'exemple mais
quand même elle peut apporter aux gens
quelque chose si la télévision ne sert
qu'à enrichir les actionnaires c'est
très grave on s'en fout avec dit que
c'était pâques était fait pour être
juste un outil pédagogique c'est fait
pour dire quand elle m'a dit j'y vois la
télé c'est aussi pas regarder vers tir
c'était forcément
moi si je dis alors je vais te dire un
truc 6 dirigé le service public ce que
je dirai aux producteurs je le redirai
voilà les émissions toutes les émissions
sont possibles à condition qu'elles
apportent tout quelque chose aux
téléspectateurs si vous faites un jeu
nous fait un jeu ok bravo il faut que ça
apporte quelque chose de d'accord un
contenu culturel école vous faites ou
fait une émission de variétés il faut
que ça apporte quelque chose cirque en
fait si je dirigeais le service public
je n'aurai pas de problème parce que le
critère de choix ça serait que les
émissions apporte quelque chose de
téléspectateurs c'est même pas appris
que faire ce qu'il a il peut faire des
variétés des jeux des machins on s'en
fout mais toujours le contenu ça amène
quoi les vérités d'entraîneur roseau
genre choisissez votre chanson ça je
vais donner si je dirigeais le service
public je dis pas on sait plus qu'à moi
ce que je ferai c'est que je dirais
daniela lumbroso vous êtes une
animatrice formidable faites-moi des
chansons le samedi à l'inter 50 parce
que c'est génial on a envie de faire des
chansons de sa vie mais démerdez vous
démerdez vous que votre émission apporte
quelque chose qui ne plus values
culturel ajouter une valeur ajoutée un
super ce qu'on appelle un supplément
d'âme et si tu veux ce que je regrette
dans la proche que tu peux avoir ou dans
celle là c'est que pour vous bah la télé
finalement pas pourquoi son maire d
apporter les choses aujourd'hui dire en
même temps de faire plus de 15% de parts
de marché parce que tu as besoin de te
vendre ta pub avant et après faire vivre
tu achètes et c'est là le débat est tout
c'est juste pour parler de culture à la
télé et c'est là on est d'accord que tom
certaines chaînes font pas diffuser un
spectacle de danse en intégrale comme ça
il faut savoir biais et ilyes
l'allaitement c'est vrai pas moisi
durant ses meilleures parts de marché il
fait quoi mais c est parce qu il nous
apprend rien n'est acquis un savoir une
âme est d'ailleurs en bus dans une
émission littéraire et une anecdote il
ya que les mecs qui parlent si vous
venez juste
résultat
on a remplacé moi je présente une
émission
qui marche bien qu'ils s'appellent ubi
qui marche bien compte tenu des
exigences de france 5 et voilà on traite
de l'actualité culturelle sous vraiment
très très large et voilà régulièrement
je me fais arrêter dans la rue par des
jeunes des cités qui m'appelle madame et
bic et la semaine dernière il y en a un
qui maritime du mozambique s'est
vachement des hans avaient parlé d'un
truc intéressant c'est une histoire de
seins de star ac de la musique classique
c'était trop la classe en fait c'était
quoi c'était un sujet sur l'académie de
william christie effectivement mode même
mode de sélection que la star ac' des
jeunes artistes lyriques sélectionné etc
il fait un spectacle avec eux c'est la
star ac version classique et ben moi
j'étais j'étais fier de mon émission
parce que grâce à sa mort d'un jeune de
cité
quand tu es sur france 2 il faut faire
de la pac mais c'est sa devise
c'est là qu'on est bêtes moi je suis sur
scène je prends part il sait pas c'est
pas un vice je t'explique intrus je fais
par exemple sur france 2 dans tout le
monde en parle je mets une chanteuse un
philosophe un acteur le philosophe au
moment où le philosophe arrive à
l'antenne l'audience des sens mais grâce
à la chanteuse et à l'acteur ça fait une
bonne moyenne bon si je suis sur tf1
parle de fuite le maigre aime dire on a
on a vu votre on a vu qu'on a vu vos
quart d'heure la samedi au moment où il
ya le philosophe ça descend si vous
évitiez le philosophe vous passez pas
directement de la chanteuse anna qui l'a
déjà dit ces mecs en plus je
n'en ai jamais vu depuis le zoo fnaim
principal danger mais c'est à dire non
si je suis dans un service public sans
puce sans pub je fais plus d'audience
urssaf et ça fait 2 % de part de marché
dire que le fait d'être obligé de faire
de l'audience nous oblige à être grand
public car le jour où il n'y a plus de
mesure de l'audience sur service public
on va faire 7% de ses très facile de
faire 7 % soit il suffit de faire
n'importe quoi tout le monde bien ça
pour ça pour arriver à faire 30 faut
déjà se lever de bonne heure donc nous
ce qu'on essaye de faire céder programme
je dis pas qu'ils sont extraordinaires
mais si tu veux d'invités glucksmann
d'invités orsenna d'invités d'ormesson
d'invités sollers d'inviter les villes
invitées ou el bec on l'aimé en train
chanteur est une star du porno et puis
ils sont là ils voient un grand public
grâce à nous le public le connaît grâce
aux journaux la philosophie se propage
tout à fait mais qui sa fille mercy
exactement mais si tu parles bien je
suis heureuse d'être venue à ta table je
dois partir malheureusement parce que je
le travaille elle est oui je vais faire
les journaux de nuit cela s'est bien
passé une travailleuse de la nuit femme
de ménage
une femme de ménage à l'aller
c'est l'envers du décor
aux etats unis quand même donc je veux
savoir si tu présentes le journal comme
ça dans cette tenue parce que la france
souvent c'était une révolution audience
non je te rassure j'ai pris ma veste de
claire chazal
à bientôt
les cent pas
à
[Musique]
et
celle
ci
un
service qui va y arriver nature de
quelqu'un en lancé par l'elysée il lui
faudra un candidat fort pour pouvoir
s'opposer à l'elysée je propose que ce
soit toi
tu irais je passe
devoir de réserve
le cesse de ces salles ne nommera jamais
quelqu'un qui n'est pas validée par
l'elysée vous allez me dire que je suis
je me suis tu pendant un long banc parce
que il ya des gens qui ont dit des tas
de choses que je pensais donc c'était
pas la peine je m'exprime le sait ça a
la possibilité de nommer des gens qui ne
plaisent pas toujours au pouvoir mais il
ne m'a jamais quelqu'un dont le pouvoir
ne veut absolument pas c'est à dire que
les noirs qui est l'actionnaire unique
de deschênes peut
contraindre le financement de ces
chaînes d'un geste voilà tout à lundi ce
qui est ce qui est vrai c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on en plus de gens de
programmes en tant que directeur de
chaîne en particulier en sommes que des
gens qui sont des apparatchiks en gros
c'est le propre de la télévision ça a
toujours été comme ça pas toujours des
gros affectées quelqu'un qui suivaient
les programmes lescure était quelqu'un
sur les programmes
les fils de m
une émission comme ça des journalistes à
la tête du service public dans ce
domaine je vous rejoins je ne sais pas
du tout ce qui se passera au mois d'août
je dirais simplement que monsieur le
lait et président de tf1 depuis 18 ans
que monsieur
taverne hausse est président depuis sept
ans eca et canal pendant quinze ans vous
avez exercé des fonctions de
responsabilité lescure et que la
continuité est important dans une
entreprise alors sur le fond des choses
pour reprendre se le dire moi je suis
pour des professionnels à la tête des
entreprises de télévision qu'elles
soient publiques ou qu'elles soient
privées à la restriction près qu'on peut
très bien trouver un énarque de qualité
ces deux-là tessier et qu'on peut
trouver je ne donnerai pas de noms des
journalistes qui sont de bons
journalistes et qu'ils sont incapables
de diriger ses chaînes de télévision
parce que c'est un vrai métier à pierre
lescure un des problèmes de pierre
lescure c'est que ça a été un formidable
patron de canal mais le fait de ne pas
venir de l'entreprise
a sûrement été une des raisons pas
trouvé son directeur général qui attaque
n'était pas le bon non mais voilà c'est
ce à quoi ça il était peut-être mais
c'est vrai que pierre a payé le fait
d'être journaliste et ne pas avoir été
un entrepreneur quant à quand t'as
jamais dirigé de société quand t'es
jamais été en contact avec le cash-flow
la marge brute la marge nette est tout
c'est difficile de déloger une boîte
mais tu vois moi ce qui me ferait
plaisir c'est que
j'aimerais bien entendre autant de
motivation par exemple sur la sur la
problématique de la non visibilité des
minorités sans on est sans loi on est
sans quotas on y sent rien je vois pas
sur qui on peut compter pour que ça
change il faut 150 ans pour changer les
mentalités c'est à dire je fais en sorte
que quand bavaro rentrer dans une
chambre et une formation et noir
le type le plus populaire mais quand le
type le plus populaire c'est un petit
arabe c'est jamel debbouze le
lalalalalala ccimn zidane est le mec
était pour laisser passer dieudonné
pardonne moi je suis absolument pas
d'accord 700 du tout c'est dieudonné le
premier avec calixte qui à défaut des
quotas c'est pas vrai du tout mais là je
trouve ça je suis d'accord avec toi sur
le fond par deux mois sheikh acta sur le
français connaissent pas renoncé à la
télé si on commence à compter les par
couleur on va compter les roues on va
compter les diabétiques entre les juifs
je suis totalement contre la dette est
le compte à leur écoute je déteste ça je
suis absolument d'accord étoiles sur le
fond je déteste parce que sous sa forme
c'est pas avec des lois ou les choses
c'est avec le talent on sera obligé de
faire des lois voilà moi j'y crois pas
je ne m'étais pas leurs cheveux déjà ses
lois attendait un temps excuse moi tu
sais quoi c'est quoi ces fraises là
c'est génial c'est quoi c'est l'effet
inverse qui est arrivé c'est la
garriguette de plougastel faisant la
bise à google avait une dégustation
autour des fraises vraiment merci du
reste c'est édifiant c'est édifiant à
compétences égales quand tu sors de la
banlieue et que tu es bac +7 c'est pas
que t'as pas de boulot tu n'as pas
d'entretien je suis absolument d'accord
avec toi je te dis geste naturel
moment-là si tu es ça donne moi je te
dis juste que je n'en ai pas
malheureusement ce que c'est c'est comme
nous en télé la solution avec une fausse
bonne solution commune où on allait à
des fausses bonnes idées cuisine hôtels
dans le monde entier nous commencions à
faire
malheureusement comment tu veux
malheureusement thierry je n'en ai marre
ils vous ont dit voilà quand il ya cinq
mecs dans un feuilleton henin qui doit
être noir et ben je vais te dire ce qui
s'est passé j'étais juste content
retaper
y'a des mails de se faire connaître
c'est quand je te dis que la télévision
comme disait thierry c'est un des
vecteurs les plus importants taux
d'intégration sociale c'est à dire que
quand tu es à la télévision tu regardes
un feuilleton banal on s'en fout c'est
bon pas bon mais qu'effectivement le
héros je te dis navarro pousse la porte
d'une pharmacie et que le pharmacien et
noir et tu te dis pas qu'il est doit se
passer un truc là sortira fin et ben non
il est juste lorsqu'il ya des
pharmaciens noir c'est toi qui lis
j'entends bouquin intéressés comme les
du robinet si elle a infecté c'est serré
d'art c'est godard dans mon bouquin
reste on verra aucun mais c'est ça mais
le problème c'est de désinfecter l'eau
c'est tout
c'est vrai que le problème risque de se
dire ce mec là il en place à cause des
quotas ils n'ont pas parce qu'il a du
talent je crois que c'est ça le risque
de dénoncer
c'est dommage je n'en ai pas l'heure
dont la tête joseph
savina des journaux demain tous les gens
en place compact avant
d'être oula ça s'appelle l'égalité des
chances philippe 80% des blonds à la
télé n'ont pas de talent je te rassure
3% ça fait beaucoup pour la terre et qui
vient le père
du trapel du petit mec avait des boutons
qu'était contre un mur etc et négation
il sortait une vanne tous les trois du
meilleur sur qu'au moment de l'âge d'or
se souvient alain ont été la toute
petite fiat 500 qui avait renouvelé à
savoir si c'est vrai qu'avec la doubler
il a fallu que je t'ai parlé j'étais
bien commencé mais c'est vrai je vais te
raconter parce que j'y étais je vais pas
raconter pour faire augmenter mon
assistante qu'était clarisse de 300
francs c'était impossible mais un
tournage à saint brieuc où les quatre
billets d'avion coûte plus cher qu'à la
new york aucun problème il y avait de
l'argent quand l'argent était à
l'antenne tout sur l'écran gildas 7e
plaisier environ 150 mille francs vers
la fin n'est par ailleurs je sais quoi
le cours du jeu qui ça quand j'allais
chercher cyril durand gagne elle ni 300
mille francs sanguin donc je vais payer
g fait d'aimer cbc il a accepté de
passer aux erreurs quand même c'est
énorme
suivraient d'agrément vd le génie de la
télévision en matériel durant 200 la
mine quand même moi je suis pas là qu'un
passage seul fait qu'ils valent et c'est
l'heure d'aller
manger un quota à respecter vos volets
un côté asexuels jeu passera d un coup
si un jour tu veux quelque chose de
spécial en pâtisserie un truc n'importe
quel disque dit pas
c'est parce que tu as beau fils et saint
martin allez bonne soirée
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu